Ron DeSantis donors are increasingly
worried that he can't handle a national
campaign for the Republican nomination
particularly against Donald Trump and I
have to tell you the evidence is
increasingly pointing that way think for
a moment we're going to get into the
data and the concerns from DeSantis
donors in a moment but think for a
moment on the one hand you have Ron
DeSantis he's got a new book he's
speaking all over the country he's going
to Staten Island and he's going to
Manhattan and he's going all over the
place speaking everywhere being
interviewed getting tons of positive
press from Fox News and his polling is
going down
and meanwhile you have Donald Trump
potentially going to get arrested any
day
holding a rally on the 30th anniversary
of the Waco Siege in Waco Texas
fomending violence all of this stuff and
his polls are going up despite middle of
the night all caps rants on Truth social
and so on and so forth that doesn't look
good for Ron DeSantis and this is indeed
the concern among many DeSantis donors
there's a good NBC news article Ron
desantis's donors and allies question if
he's ready for 2024. at a recent
Gathering of 16 prominent Republicans a
number of DeSantis supporters discussed
if he should run against Trump or wait
until 2028 and that 2028 question we've
increasingly been talking about many of
you have emailed me and said DeSantis
although he looks like he's almost 60
he's only 44 years old he could wait he
could wait until 2028 when there will be
no Trump he could even wait until 2032
if he wanted to it's not clear that with
the higher polling he would be willing
to do that but if the polling declines
maybe he would NBC News writes Ron
DeSantis may be missing his moment a
number of his donors and allies are
worried uh his recent stumble suggests
he may not be ready for a a brutal fight
against Donald Trump some field DeSantis
needs to accelerate his timeline to run
for the Republican nomination and begin
directly confronting Trump if he is to
have any chance of thwarting Trump's
momentum others believe DeSantis should
sidestep Trump altogether and wait until
2028. it is true that with the
anticipation having built for months and
months now Donald Trump having announced
in the days right after the November of
22 midterms and actively campaigning at
this point his first rally was over the
weekend and we'll talk about that
how long can DeSantis build anticipation
at the beginning you can accurately say
he's building anticipation and he's
pulling strongly as he starts to misstep
as his lack of Charisma oozes out of
every pore and as his polling starts to
sort of drift down
we can no longer call it building
anticipation it's something else and
maybe it is missing the moment the
article continues at a Sunday luncheon
it's not a lunch it's a luncheon and
that's how you know it's serious
business at a Sunday luncheon following
the annual Red Cross ball in Palm Beach
Florida a group of 16 prominent
Republicans described by one attendee as
a mix of DeSantis backers and Trump
Skeptics discussed misgivings about the
sandus is standing for the future if he
tussles with the former president quote
they liked him many of them might even
support him but they thought on balance
that his long-term future was better
without him trying to take Trump head on
he will get scarred up
um the article mentions some specific
donors including billionaire shipping
Goods magnate Richard
Uline and his wife Elizabeth whose five
hundred thousand dollars in Combined
contributions make them among the most
generous donors to DeSantis 2022
campaign
um a person familiar with the strategy
around Uline spending said that right
now quote the breaks are pumped the
polling really made different people
pause a spokesperson for the ulines is
declining to comment it is absolutely
true
that the polling is no Beauty to write
home about if you look at recent polling
you do see that it's very solid for
Trump in just about every way a very
recent Harris X Harris poll has Trump 12
ahead of DeSantis and that's one of
that's one of desantis's better
standings to be perfectly Frank uh a
premise poll has Trump 24 ahead of
DeSantis among registered voters and 30
ahead among all respondents uh a yugov
poll has trumped 15 ahead of DeSantis
now the Counterpoint is DeSantis hasn't
even announced yet and having numbers
this strong when you're not even running
suggests that if DeSantis announces he's
going to get a surge a boost a swelling
for lack of a better term of his polling
that may be the case the problem is as I
mentioned that's a stronger argument
before everybody's talking about
DeSantis for four months and he's doing
interviews and book tours and speeches
and getting the best possible press he
can get from Fox News
once you have months and months of that
it starts to feel as though his
potential is increasingly baked into
existing polling and there's less of a
boost to be had with an announcement so
I don't know what's going to happen it's
not for me to advise Republicans nor is
anybody asking me to advise Republicans
but my concern for DeSantis from day one
has been his lack of Charisma and
seeming desire to be above Trump when
he's asked well Trump said this what do
you say he says I don't spend my time
criticizing Republicans uh fine that may
that may play well in Florida but it's
not striking me as the strongest
positioning for fighting Trump in a
national campaign I want to hear from
you what do you think about desantis's
chances as we are about to enter April
of 2023 are they deflate relating can
they still be pumped up let me know what
you think in a comment we'll follow up
and see what's on your minds did you
know that every year 30 million trees
are cut down to meet the demand of
toilet paper in the United States alone
here's something really simple you can
do to fight climate change a little bit
in your home our sponsor real paper
makes toilet paper 100 percent from
bamboo stocks which keep growing forever
no trees are cut down it's shipped right
to your door in plastic free packaging
it's fluffy it's soft like regular
toilet paper you're not making any
quality sacrifice and for every box you
buy real paper donates to reforestation
efforts Across America through their
partnership with one tree planted so
instead of the toilet paper you're
currently buying which cuts down trees
and wastes plastic use real paper
actively helping the planet you can set
up a recurring subscription so you're
always stocked or do a one-time purchase
is the average American uses 50 pounds
of toilet paper or more every year make
the easy switch to real paper you'll get
30 off your first order plus free
shipping go to realpaper.com Pacman and
use the code Pacman the link is down
below